beaucoup plus
fort que nous moi j'espère que plus tard
justement on sera on sera tous à égalité
et qu'on pourra tous faire ce qu'on veut
on ayant l'esprit de sympathique pour
tout le monde qui est pas ah toi tu
m'embêtes va faire ta cuisine et
m'embête pas tu vois moi je fais un
métier et puis toi tu restes là-bas et
qu'on puisse tous se parler gentiment
sans
se Condé enfin
sans se dire des grossièreté enfin je
pense que
enfin j'espère plutôt que les hommes
on ne sait pas c'est un petit peu devant
on soit pas tout le temps derrière les
Suisses comme si on était
d'ailleurs on est en ce moment on est
tout à fait sous-estimer
et j'aimerais aussi qu'on puisse dire
nos opinions sans qu'on nous dise mais
non vous êtes vous avez aucune opinion
juste aller en arrière